carrusel de las artes maría carolina
piña
[Música]
les damos la bienvenida a este número
especial de carrusel de las artes
estamos en la cinemateca de la ciudad de
toulouse en el marco de cine latino y
tenemos el gran honor esta vez de
recibir en nuestro programa al actor
chileno alfredo castro una figura
central del teatro y del cine no
solamente de chile sino también de
américa latina gracias a alfredo por
estar con nosotros muy contento de estar
acá en este marco de epidemia mundial en
esta circunstancia especial es casi un
privilegio poder verlo de este lado del
mundo y usted ha tenido aquí en cine
latino un encuentro con el público como
ha sido de ser reanudar con los amantes
del cine y con los amantes del cine
latinoamericano bueno con mucha
esperanza me fue muy difícil salir de
chile la situación no es buena en
sudamérica es muy compleja pero pude
poder salir y para mí fue un despertar
así volver a ver gente volver a ver la
película en tony manero en 35 y conocer
el festival de toulouse que yo no lo
conocía
nunca me impresiona la calidad humana de
las personas que lo hacen los conocí a
todos ya todas y no lo podía creer gente
que pasó de la militancia política del
apoyo a la en contra de las dictaduras
en latinoamérica el apoyo a los
exiliados chilenos en fin un apoyo
político humano una solidaridad
maravillosa y pasaron con el tiempo a
este campo el arte de la creación del
cine que estoy fascinado estoy feliz de
estar acá de verdad justamente este año
sí en el latino le han hecho un homenaje
especial a usted con una selección de
sus películas desde justamente tony
manero que fue muy importante aquí en
europa también hasta dos de sus últimas
películas tengo miedo torero de rodrigo
sepúlveda y carnaval de juan pabló feliz
y yo quería justamente que habláramos de
esa película tengo miedo torero una
película que es una adaptación del libro
del mismo nombre de una figura muy
importante en chile que es pedro lemebel
y que lo sedujo de llevar esa historia
de uno
sexual marginado muy sensible en la
época de la dictadura militar en chile y
llevar esa historia al cine yo allí el
de rendir homenaje a pedro lemebel él
fue un activista lgtb de cumas muy
importante en chile que luchó mucho por
los derechos de la comunidad gay y la
comunidad del g20 con más con acciones
de arte con un performista muy
importante y que escribió esta novela
que cuenta la historia de una pasión un
amor entre un travesti viejo es muy
pobre muy degradado muy triste con un
muchacho joven precioso revolucionario
que va a hacer un atentado contra el
dictador pinochet genocida pinochet y es
una historia real que tiene una cuota de
ficción muy importante y fue increíble
hacerla porque pedro lemebel hace unos
15 años él me entregó a mí en persona me
dijo yo creo que tú hagas el personaje
de la loca del frente
y quiero aclarar algo para mejor
comprensión de la película en chile el
partido comunista tiene una escisión con
un grupo armado durante la dictadura
se llamaba el frente patriótico manuel
rodríguez entonces la película cuenta el
viaje y biológico de esta loca se le
dice la loca del frente la loca del
frente patriótico manuel rodríguez y
también la loca que vive al frente o la
loca que tú tienes al frente
hay un juego de palabras que puede ser
incomprensible para algunos países y lo
aclaro porque interesante el juego ese
de palabra no lo primero que me propuse
fue otorgarle la dignidad a ese rol que
se merecía y que pedro lemebel defendió
con mucho ahínco en su vida que se
tratara con dignidad entonces no voy a
contar la película pero hay una defensa
del rol del travesti el revolucionario
luchador solidario quien para mí fue muy
importante hacer ese papel
[Música]
los personajes que usted ha guardado en
el cine tienen mucho de políticos
también abordan cuestiones sociales muy
importantes en esta película tengo miedo
torero quizás hay mucho de eso mucho de
la sociedad chilena de una época en
especial para usted el cine y el teatro
porque usted es un hombre de teatro
también tiene que tener ese ese tinte
político debe tenerlo creo que se no no
tiene razón de ser no creo que uno yo
creo que el teatro en el cine debe tener
una cuota de peligro que deben poner al
espectador en peligro un peligro
simbólico un peligro real un peligro del
cuerpo donde más que tener respuesta se
plante en preguntas que se plantee en
realidades sociales
que conmueven al espectador realmente
soy un actor que ha entrado a sus roles
por la emoción y por lo político a quien
se le latino también pudimos ver
películas como algunas bestias que va a
salir en francia- quizás el año próximo
vimos también el club que trata sobre la
pedofilia en la iglesia católica y en
algunas bestias tiene que ver con el
incesto esos personajes monstruosos
perversos tampoco le dan miedo si me dan
miedo y tienen su costo también es
interpretarlo la elección de esos roles
ha sido porque yo creo que cumplen una
función política muy importante
algunas bestias es una película que fue
filmada en 10 días en situación con un
equipo muy pequeño y que no habla
solamente sobre una familia es el
retrato de un país donde el abuso
de menores de edad el abuso de poder el
abuso sexual el abuso económico el abuso
de clase está muy presente no es que me
importa a mí
lucir me en un rol sobre la pedofilia o
el abuso me importa que la película
toque el de un tema social que tanto en
francia como en españa como en venezuela
como en cualquier país es un tema que
todos sabemos que está presente que hay
que parar con eso y yo creo que el arte
visibiliza esos secretos horrorosos que
una sociedad debe ponerle fin en chile o
en los otros países latinoamericanos que
tenemos historias convulsas y
complicadas quedan temas por explorar
alfredo que todavía usted no ha tocado y
que le gustaría llevar bueno piensa que
la pandemia ha despertado en un ser
humano desconocido un ser humano
tremendamente perverso y cruel
el jurista y un ser humano tremendamente
vulnerable tremendamente solidario
amoroso yo creo que han surgido nuevos
temas sobre todo que tienen que ver con
la emigración con la frontera que
carnaval lo retrata muy bien con el
trabajo infantil con la explotación y
que me hacen pensar que debe venir un
cine muy fuerte ahora con la naturaleza
en chile hay ríos que han vuelto a tener
su caudal han vuelto las aguas a la
donde tenían que estar creo que hemos
sido muy violentos y brutales con la
naturaleza y si no entendemos ahora no
entenderemos nunca pero yo tengo la
esperanza de que un nuevo ser humano
puede surgir de acá una nueva sociedad
bueno y esperando ese cine que refleje
un nuevo ser humano te agradecemos
alfredo castro haber dado con nosotros y
haber respondido a nuestras preguntas en
la rochelle de las artes
muchas gracias a usted si algún día hace
una revolución que incluya las locas
avísame
hoy voy a estar en primera fila
[Música]
de tu luz vamos a parís para conocer a
una diva moderna de la escena musical
francesa se llama oms y nuestra
compañera de antel olivares conversó con
ella
[Música]
hasta el no
estamos en el distrito cuatro de parís
cerquita de la plaza de la bastilla en
el esfuerzo nacional y nos vamos de
paseo por el sena con olivia mediátic la
cantante de u2 se lanza en una carrera
solista y nos habla de su nuevo proyecto
fue 2 en el barco
y puedo decirte que fue un peligro hacer
un proyecto sola porque de repente me
encontré experimentando sin tener a
nadie que me diera su opinión como lo
era antes y todo el tiempo hubo tal
intercambio con dan cuando formamos el
dúo de dúo que siempre estábamos juntos
vivíamos juntos hoy trabajo sola y tengo
ya mis costumbres como solista para mí
es un proyecto de emancipación de
liberación y también de afirmación de mi
identidad
[Música]
tú vienes de una carrera de 10 años con
un grupo que se llama 22 ahora se
emprende sola de manera independiente en
el gran proyecto que se llama james
porque este nombre de persona a persona
no necesitaba un alter ego y un nombre
para mi proyecto porque sentía que
necesitaba salir de mi cotidianidad y
tener a un otro escudamos es un nombre
que me inspira musicalmente
estéticamente y para mí también es muy
multidimensional es al mismo tiempo un
nombre una palabra una virtud y varias
representaciones mitológicas también y
es una canción de los beatles o fueron
muchas cosas y al final es un poco
recargado pero ilustra muy bien mi
universo como
[Música]
hay un concepto del que me gusta hablar
llamado si es un estado de ánimo
finlandés es propio de los holandeses es
una especie de fuerza interior que al
origen permiten atravesar los largos
inviernos es algo que te ayuda a
resistir mucho tome puesto y yo sentía
que ese álbum tomaba mucho tiempo en
salir mientras tanto tuve un amigo y
después hubo la pandemia había muchas
cosas que retrasaban obstáculos que
teníamos que superar al tiempo que
teníamos que seguir creyendo en el
proyecto seguir adelante con la misma fe
por eso creo en el sismo porque me
aportó bastante en ese bello gesto y si
es verdad mis orígenes finlandeses me
dieron la fuerza y me acompañaron en
todo esto muchísimas gracias olivia fue
donada por habernos recibido en este
barco francés remató con fe estamos
pasando por los monumentos parisinos
luis sanluis una balada para reconectar
a nuestra manera con la naturaleza
muchísimas gracias orilla gracias
[Música]
gracias natal y olivares y con esto
ponemos punto final a este programa
especial que les presentamos desde la
ciudad de toulouse muchísimas gracias
por su sintonía y hasta la próxima
aguayo
[Música]
e
aquí
[Música]